coups de feu en cuisine ces chefs ont
trois heures pour réaliser un dessert au
sein de l'école lenôtre
il participe à un concours de pâtisserie
sous l'oeil attentif du chef étoilé
frédéric anton quoi ils sont très
organisés très propre et puis on voit
qu'ils qu'ils emploient des techniques
même au delà de certains professionnels
donc ça c'est beau à voir parmi ces
cuisiniers des directeurs
d'établissement des infirmières ou
encore des aides-soignantes chacun forme
un binôme avec un chef du groupe korian
leur point commun ils travaillent tous
dans cette entreprise de gestion
d'établissements pour personnes âgées à
l'origine de cette initiative
ce concours c'était vraiment ali
l'origine c'était de mettre à l'honneur
le métier de chef de cuisine de
cuisinier dans un établissement de prise
en charge de la personne âgée
l'école lenôtre c'est ici le lieu je
dirais le coeur le coeur du réacteur
on est en travaillent maintenant
ensemble en partenariat depuis plus d'un
an et demi et c'est le lieu de
l'excellence les cuisiniers du groupe
korian servent près de soixante mille
repas par jour participer à ce concours
c'est une formation en plus et un
nouveau challenge
comme pour david ce chef bourguignon a
élaboré son dessert avec marie-hélène la
directrice de son établissement
et toi sans cela la démarche est engagée
depuis déjà quelques temps avec la
dérision hébergement d'avoir une
amélioration de la qualité au niveau de
la restauration donc de cours
apporter justement cette ce petit
pistons d'un concours dans les locaux
des moulins autres c'est forcément un
plus les gagnants du concours sont de
niçoises respectivement cuisinière et
psychologues
elles auront la chance de suivre une
formation à l'école lenôtre leur dessert
sera par la suite réalisé et distribué
dans les trois cent soixante cinq
établissements du groupe